[Music]
hello hi there
how are you getting on bud
yeah you're really good thank you so
much for letting me call you
that's okay how are you finding nelson
it's uh
oh finding my way around pretty italy
people are lovely weather is good can't
complain
how good with the weather today
oh it's lovely very good very good
it's always always like that here
is that yeah well that's good to know
dory sunny
well that's good to know well what's uh
what's happening well the reason i
wanted to call you is i like to
call all my new players that come to the
tasman marcos
i think it's really important for the
sponsors to sort of get to know them
excellent so what i've done in the past
is i've had some of the boys around for
dinner or movies or
et cetera and i'm just wondering if that
would be of any interest to you maybe
sometime this week
oh yeah mate yeah like i said like i'm
just uh could all in
sorry obviously got my contact details
you cut
out there sorry what was that pencil
something under the next big one
yeah yeah so
you've got my contact details so there
should be no dramas oh perfect because
i've just bought a new big projector for
my bedroom
and i was pretty keen to test that out
so i was wondering if you'd be
quite keen to come around and maybe
watch one of your favorite films some
night
oh yeah
yeah it's pretty uh pretty full on with
the old training schedule since i'm
since i'm new so
yeah that's uh i think you've got it's
gonna be a
pretty busy week this week third day off
i think if you want to
come around wednesday night
yeah i'll uh i'll see you see what the
schedule looks like for the for the week
and we'll um
we'll get back to you oh that'd be
awesome because i've got lots of wine in
my
um cupboards and lots of popcorn if you
if you get hungry or
thirsty oh it sounds good
any films that come to mind that you'd
like me to
pre-order uh not at the moment
i haven't really uh i've got the easy um
get the kids picked i've got now i've
got four to see so
okay so you you'll be all over the world
a lot of movies
so maybe this is a because your kids
aren't won't be coming all day so maybe
it's a good chance
i've actually got some new adult films
just come out if you
if they're of any interest to you
all right so let's just see how things
go over the next few days and
okay this this past week so
so we won't lock anything for wednesday
not at this stage